hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on apex again and we
have a little bit of information to talk
about we have some stuff from the
developers they talked about new hop ups
and new Magazine stuff ways that they
can diversify the magazines and how
those are gonna be spawning within game
because I remember before the energy
magazines were just super rare to get
another a lot more common and then
there's actually a few ways to make the
P 2020 the Mozambique and all that stuff
a lot more viable and I think it's gonna
be a lot more viable she's always like
the V if you do enjoy subscribe before
new I covered the informational side of
Apex legends so that everyone is caught
up to date with everything happening
within the world of Apex
I also cover the lore of Apex legends I
recently just covered Watson in her
backstory so you could check that video
that's popping up on screen right now or
you can check the video at the end of
this video as well in the endcard so you
can always see that so in this post they
talked about the new L star weapon if
you're a titanfall thin if you played
the first two games you already know
what the L star is but for you apex
players the L star is a very popular
weapon that came out and titanfall 1 and
2 and of course it's gonna become an
apex since they're set in the same
universe
it is a plasma fuel of power but it
comes at a price the L star will
overheat if players hold on the trigger
too long so you have to feather that
trigger a little bit in short to medium
burst to make sure the weapon doesn't
overheat the L star is also only going
to be spawning in air drops just like
the Mastiff and the craver and will come
with its own ammo supply so you will
have to get a new L star if you want to
keep it so I'm assuming because it is a
gold weapon in the air drops it's going
to be a very powerful weapon at that on
top of that they added new hop ups we
talked about a couple weeks ago that
they would be adding two new hop ups we
have but we had no idea what they would
be and these so far are gonna be the
disrupter rounds and the hammer point
rounds so disrupter rounds will do
increased damage to it up an opponent
shield and the hammer point rounds to
increase damage to an opponent's health
bar so for the disruptor rounds the two
weapons that will be compatible with
this is the alternator in the re 45 and
for the hammer point rounds it's going
to be the P 2020 in the Mozambique so
finally the two shittiest weapons in the
game the P 2020 and the Mozambique have
a hop up and this might I personally
think this will make it a lot more
viable when I've been using the
Mozambique I get maybe 20 damage but 42
if I'm lucky with hammer point rounds
increasing the amount of damage they get
to unshielded opponents this is going to
be helping a lot more and seeing as the
Mozambique is a very common what
you're gonna be getting that before a
lot of players get their shield so
that's going to be dropping players a
lot more quickly and it will actually be
something you can use as opposed to just
leaving on the floor and leaving so
honestly I think this is a good idea and
that's why I think personally that these
two weapons are gonna become a lot more
viable I know the developers talked
about that they wanted to make some
shitty weapons which is why those [ __ ]
weapons are more common that being the
Mozambique and the P 2020 but honestly
it's laughable how terrible their
damages and it's not even worth picking
up sometimes I even just use my fists
instead cuz it does more damage but I
think this is gonna be great and as for
the alternator and the re 45 they're not
incredibly powerful but they are still
damaged doable and I just think that the
disruptor rounds are gonna be a lot more
effective because that's one of the
problems with those guns is that the re
45 you fire to it has a huge fire rate
and the alternator doesn't fire as fast
and when an opponent has a really big
shield like a purple of gold or even a
blue it can be a really big pain in the
ass and you waste about the entire clip
just take off the shield so I think
having more damage to the shield that's
gonna be a lot more useful so I think
this was a really good call they're also
going to be adding a new attachment
called energy magazines and this is
going to be for all energy weapons being
the triple take the devotion and the
havoc and this is very similar to a
light extended mag or a heavy extended
mag where it increases the amount of
ammo you're going to be getting and of
course the reload time but this is only
going to be for energy weapons one of
the things you may have noticed is that
there is the heavy extended mag for all
the heavy weapons the wingmen the
hemlock etc and then the light magazine
for the alternator re 45 all that type
of stuff but there wasn't one for the
energy weapons and that was a huge
problem I have what the havoc is because
there isn't enough ammo which is why I
always pick the devotion over it but I
think now having the havoc being a
little bit more buffed as of the recent
patch and this increased magazine size I
think the havoc is gonna be a lot more
better and also I think the triple take
is gonna be better as well just cuz
you're gonna get more ammo because I
think it's like four to five shots you
get with your clip and that's just
really not enough even with the
precision choke you're gonna need a lot
more so they finally decided to add
energy magazine so that's a great deal
for them they're also gonna be buffing a
lot more of the lesser popular weapons
so they said to look out for their
season two patch notes when that comes
out and that's going to be buffing
weapons like the flatline the P 2020 the
alternator and the trip will take very
good call on that one
the
but the flatline in my opinion is the
worst heavy weapon in the entire game
even after all the wingmen nervous I
still think that the flatline is garbage
and I will that is the least popular
weapon in my arsenal the P 2020
alternator of course those are garbage
as well and the trip will take is ok
don't know why this is being buffed but
I mean I'll take a buff regardless still
a solid weapon they're also gonna be
buffing and nerfing the arc star one of
the problems is that it just shreds your
shield when you get even far away from
it and then it blows up really quickly
is there gonna be delaying that time
from 2.5 seconds to 2.8 so it's gonna
take a little bit longer blow up if you
stick a full health player it will now
down them instantly instead of just
disrupting their shields or only doing
like 75% of their health it will kill
them instantly and then players at the
edge of the explosion will no longer get
their shields completely shredded as
long as you're within that range it
might do a bar or two but it won't do
the entire shield which is huge
because the arc stars are one of the
best grenades in the game and that
ability to just shred an entire
opponent's shield regardless of how far
they are is pretty damaging so I'm glad
that this was nerfed they also said that
players can look forward to finding a
totally new set of gold weapons in Kings
Canyon for the start of season two we'll
have to look at the season two patch on
so when they release that I'm gonna be
very curious to see what they mean by
gold weapons there's a few weapons in
the game of course that we don't have
fully gold parts of I really don't know
what that means maybe we'll get like a
Mozambique gold variant I think that'd
be cool or some other random weapon that
we don't really have I don't think the
devotion of the triple take have a gold
barian so that can be a thing and then
some of the other weapons like a flat
line or a hemlock because personally if
that is a thing I've never got them
before and they also nerfed and buffed
the ammo stack so of course which we all
know with backpacks we have to basically
consider what ammo we're gonna bring it
to the fight and then also what kind of
equipment we're gonna be bringing and so
they ended up nerfing and buffing the
shotgun and energy mags so the shotgun
mag for the multiple stack that you can
carry instead of carrying 64 of per
stack it's going to be 16 so you're
gonna be needing multiple stacks to run
a shotgun thus making maybe two shotguns
not as more useful anymore and then the
energy mags are gonna be increased from
60 to 80 to now match the light and
heavy ammo which is great one of the
problems I always didn't like about the
energy is that there wasn't enough that
you could carry so that's a good buff of
course but I'm not really sure how much
I feel about the shotgun that's a
literally four
less than what it was before that might
make shotguns completely useless even
though the damage for those weapons are
great carrying a lot is going to mean
you're gonna be carrying a lot less
shields a lot less grenades and it might
not just keep you available to fight at
the endgame so I'm not sure how that's
going to be playing out left to see when
it happens in season two and then also
loot tables are gonna be introduced for
air drop packages so basically what that
means in the early and mid game you're
gonna be seeing a lot more cravers and
supply drops and those air drops while
at the endgame you're gonna be seeing a
lot more Mastiffs they're also going to
be including loot tables for the lstart
of the new weapon that's coming in
season two we don't know exactly how
common that's gonna be whether it'd be
more common as with the craver or the
mastiff I personally think the L star is
a very powerful weapon so I think it's
probably gonna be in the back towards
the endgame with the Mastiff but just so
you know if you do see a Supply Drop in
the very beginning of the game and most
likely will have a crater in season two
and yeah that's just about it remember
guys season two is gonna be releasing in
July second so honestly in about half a
month very excited to play I'm very
excited to see what they're gonna be
adding and hopefully the devs have
listened and hopefully the battle past
is also really good as well we still
don't actually know what all 100 levels
or I think it's 50 now the battle paths
of what it's gonna be but I'm very
excited to see what that's gonna look
like I hope it's gonna be good that's
the one problem with season 1 is that it
was absolutely terrible
no wonder they like that I was
originally gonna get to level 110 but I
stopped after like 70 because I was just
so bored and I really didn't get a lot
of rewards for how long I played so
we'll see it we'll have to see how that
goes in season 2 so look out for a video
on that B I like the view if you do
enjoy guys subscribe if you're new I
covered the informational side of apex
legends so you want to be kept up to
date with everything happening just
definitely stay subscribe to the channel
I also cover the lore of Apex legends I
covered the war of octane the newest
character in season 1 and I also covered
the lore of Watson the newest character
in season 2 so as I said you can click
one of my second recent videos that'll
be popping up on screen in a bit I
really highly recommend the Watson video
it's really interesting to see how she
actually fits into the game and she's
very important to the game actually yeah
but that guys take care enjoy the rest
your day and peace out
you